m
here.
♪ ♪
[Cheers and applause]
>> It's a glorious Wednesday, or
as cat calls it, two days from
vodka.
I kid, she's never gone two days
without vodka.
Before we get to the news
however, it's time for --
Musical physical >> Announcer:
Greg seven jokes.
>> Greg: Resident Biden has
canceled trick-or-treating at
the White House for Halloween.
When asked why, Joe responded,
children wearing costumes and
going house to house for candy
travel trivializes the very
thing we are salivating.
At the birth of.
[Laughter]
Comedian Kathy Griffin posted a
video of her shaking her from a
balcony in Los Angeles.
Authorities reported that the
first time they've seen migrants
turnaround of the border and
head home.
We don't need a wall.
California Governor Gavin Newsom
has mandated coded vaccines for
all state employees, but less
than two-thirds have complied
to.
Can't fault them in
San Francisco.
For some reason there's a
shortage of needles.
[Laughter]
Sportscaster Joe bucket claims
he once in a bottle while
calling an NFL touchdown.
Big deal.
I once in a bottle on "the five"
or doing on animals are great
segment.
Then I told kill meat it was
Gatorade.
He didn't mind at all.
A Minnesota surgeon was fired
for telling a school board to
let parents make decisions about
Mexican kids that come up which
makes total sense.
I mean, what does a surgeon know
about masks?
[Laughter]
>> A sexist would say.
>> Greg: A sexist would say.
That didn't even get a laugh,
Tyrus.
What's with this crowd?
Some New York schools are
banning any costumes based on a
"Squid Game" which depicts mass
murder.
And stores are pulling all the
witches costumes because the
hosts on it "the video"
considerate cultural
appropriation.
[Applause]
Note to self.
Make all jokes about "The View."
A hike or loss for 24 hours
ignored calls from rescuers
because it came from an unknown
number.
Even worse, he was in a
Bed Bath & Beyond.
And that was my seven jokes.
[Cheers and applause]
>> Greg: All right.
America, get ready for more
crime.
I'm so excited.
We should all stand up and do
the wave, except this is a crime
wave.
So if we sit back down, our
wallets will be gone.
Last night I went to dinner and
you know what I didn't get?
Murdered.
That's quite a feat when you
consider I had the jalapeno
poppers at the Times Square
Applebee's.
So as you can tell, I'm not
dead.
But for how long?
Last night, we told you about
Biden's 42 page plan to promote
gender equity.
That's one page for every
gender.
[Laughter]
Inside the plane is a proposal
to eliminate cash bail for
suspects.
Not just the ones for the
initials HB.
This happens as repeat offenders
have been killing and injuring
people thanks to the new policy.
It's turning repeat offenders
and to repeat, repeat, repeat
offenders.
It's like binge watching will
and grace.
We have heard the examples, and
in Virginia a man beats up his
spouse and gets released on a no
cash bail and then he killed
her.
The many attacks here on women,
some resulting in death, all
done by thugs that have been
arrested and then released.
Some of those were not in the 42
page plan on gender equity.
The radical DAs behind us
don't seem to mind may be
because it's working out the way
that it wanted to.
Nothing shouts flow the
revolution, including murder.
You have to break a few eggs to
make an omelette and instead of
eggshells it's gun shells.
The media is there to help out.
Every time we mention the
homicides rates, what do you
hear?
Other violent crime has gone
down.
Take the "L.A. Times" reporting
that California had a 31% jump
in homicides but, they point out
that the states faring better on
other violent crime.
Well, that's good to know.
It's good to know that when
someone attacks you, they are
going to finish the job.
[Laughs]
Meanwhile, San Francisco
families are hiring private
security to keep them safe.
I'm curious, how wealthy are
these families since they can
afford this?
More importantly did they vote
Democrat?
Because clearly they can afford
that, too.
If you are living in SF instead
of moving and you hire private
guards, you must be doing
all right.
You are doing so well that you
can avoid the hill that harms
other people.
That's a kind of privatization
that with liberals love.
Maybe it's time to introduce
bills that ban private security
by Democrats.
They can throw no cash bail out
on us, can we throw that right
back at them?
If you support no cash bail, why
should you live in safety of the
rest of us can't?
It's a direct result of your
stupid destructive decisions
like flashing police budgets or
putting pop rocks and cats of a
pen.
But you see the power,
Democrats -- in force on others
and as long as they are in power
they can dance mask lists in
public and eat in a fancy
restaurant while you are under
house arrest.
[BLEEP] some can even marry
their brother.
[Laughter]
That must've been a cozy wedding
when they asked guests if they
were relatives of the bride and
groom, I just said yes.
Talk about dysfunctional.
As Minneapolis gets worse and
worse, mentally Ilhan Omar calls
the cops dysfunctional but
that's like me calling anyone
drop-dead gorgeous.
Talk about the pot calling the
kettle black, know what I'm
saying?
Or in this case the wife calling
the brother husband.
But meanwhile a grandmother must
take two extra buses to find a
Walgreens after they all closed
in the neighborhood due to the
retail theft by liberal leaders.
We wish the Democrat party Might
rediscover common sense but they
won't.
They won.
Now they see their experiment in
action.
Burnt out cities, record
homicide rates, including as a
recreational behavior, rapes and
schools covered up by slacks.
It's not exactly a brochure for
sandals resorts and pushing it
demands even more.
You could say they are a glutton
for punishment except they are
not getting punished, you are.
[Applause]
Tonight's guests, he left the
Democratic Party in the 80s
and it's the only time he ever
left the party in the 80s.
Former director of the National
economic Council and host of
Kudlow on FOX Business,
Larry Kudlow.
[Cheers and applause]
She is so sharp she carves
pumpkins with her thoughts.
A contributor to the spectator,
Kate high.
And she wants a scary costume,
she can just take her hair
extensions out.
FOX News contributor Kat Timpf.
And he's stronger than hippies
DO after running the Miami
marathon, though N.W.A. world
Champion Tyrus.
So I want you to know that
despite my terrible choice and
socks I work or pinstripes for
you.
>> You picked up your whole
game.
>> Greg: I have picked up my
game because you know what, we
are winning.
And that's when you pick it up.
So am I missing something?
Why double down on some kind of
policy that everyone can see is
killing people?
No one can deny that this is bad
policy, what is the underlying
thing?
>> I think the far left
Democratic Party, the
progressives, hate cops and they
want to do everything they
cannot to help cops and no bail,
no cash bail, know any bail.
But the revolving door it come
about recidivism.
I thought your opening was
exactly right.
We have it here in New York and
it's awful.
You talk to almost anybody in
law enforcement and they want to
repost bail.
Keep them in, keep them locked
up for a while.
And I want go one step further
and I want to end of century
cities.
I think they have been hiding
illegal immigrants who are
committing crimes constantly.
Recidivism, and illegal
immigrants is a terrible plague
and people have been killed time
and time again.
And they will not report it to
the federal cops or the FBI and
I think that's a catastrophe and
I think that should be changed.
In fact I want no sanctuary
cities throughout the country at
all.
>> Greg: I would be okay with
sanctuary cities if there were
centuries for things I like to
do.
Right?
You know what I'm saying.
>> Yes.
>> Greg: You can have a
Century City for illegal aliens,
what about other illegal
activities that I like to
participate in?
Then we could talk sanctuary
cities.
Right?
[Applause]
You noticed Kate I have not seen
said what my illegal activity
is.
>> Very smart.
>> Exactly.
And I'm not ever going to say
what it is.
Maybe.
Call me.
Anyway, it could equity be --
could it raise the murder rate
of women?
So is equal to men?
Is that what this is about?
>> You have it exactly right.
It's the equality of insecurity.
That's a equity that we are
going for because we can't have
safety across the board, we are
going to make everyone safe but
you are not going to be safe in
the city, you can't be safe in
the suburbs.
And what you're talking about
was San Francisco was really
interesting.
Actually heard that the cast of
Fuller house is now equipped
with AR-15s.
>> Greg: It really yeah.
But seeing what the Democrats to
across the board, if it there is
something bad you have to make
it bad for everyone and the best
solution, you said they were
hiring security and whatnot but
the best solution I think is
actually to get out of
San Francisco, up and move to
Florida, Texas, anywhere else.
>> Greg: The only problem is
they often bring about ideas
with them.
The lady over there Tyrus, makes
a good point.
She says that when things are
bad the Democrat solution is to
make it bad for everybody rather
than fix the bad.
I think that's a very cogent
point.
By that lady sitting over there.
>> You forgot her name again,
didn't you?
>> Her name is Kate.
She's a lady.
>> Is the only good point I've
ever made.
>> I think we are being a little
too tough on the Democrats.
I mean attempted murder is down.
It's way down.
>> Greg: You know what's
funny?
They murdered.
You can't have both.
>> Right.
There's nothing worse than
someone trying to kill you and
you call the police and the
police come get them and he's
going away for a long time,
don't you worry.
And your son is like, bye, bad
guy.
17 minutes later, oh, he has a
key.
And the murder happens.
That's literally what America is
looking at now.
Then they are like well, because
their definition of equality has
nothing to do with equality,
because America is really about
equality of opportunity.
It's not everyone's equal.
Because I am not equal with a.
I'm not equal with a man who
beats his wife every night, I'm
not.
So when they try to say that's
their whole plan, I think --
whoever is running on the
Republican party, I would wait.
I wouldn't say anything now but
try this.
Let's stop -- it doesn't matter
your sexual orientation, your
gender or the color of your
skin.
Let's start focusing on people's
character.
Because character is the only
thing that you can count on.
>> Greg: Definitely,
absolutely.
You know, Kat, no cash bail
would have been a great thing
when you were dating.
>> Yeah.
It would have saved me a lot of
money.
>> Greg: It would have.
You get married and they go and
get rid of the no cash bail
totally screwing you over.
>> It's almost like a personal
affront to me.
Now that I'm no longer dating
convicts and married to a
wonderful man.
>> Yeah we don't have to hear
that hole, it do I pay rent or
bail him out?
>> If I did neither, neither of
us would have a place to live.
Months to get rid of that guy,
he's always breaking his foot.
>> At stuff from the couch to
the fridge.
>> Oh, yeah.
Anything else?
I want to be safe.
I do.
I don't want to give anyone any
ideas but I'm very memorable.
I mean, I'm also not allowed to
have a gun so what I can do if
someone tries to kill me, I can
just go, no!
That's it.
And I don't think that's quite a
match for a murder.
>> Can I just go back to -- I
mean I love Tyrus.
I'm afraid of him but I love
him.
He's got his champions belt on.
But I'm glad there's a lot of
distance.
Equality of opportunity.
Look.
You mentioned how the
billionaires have their own
security and I admit that there
is some hypocrisy there.
But Greg, I want to be here to
defend billionaires.
I basically want to help them
out, and I think they take too
much flak.
Billionaires do wonderful
things.
To create businesses, tens of
millions of jobs, higher wages
and they need support groups.
People like myself have to stand
up and support them and the
reason I said equality of
opportunity is, these lefty
Democrats want to punish
success.
And I don'